روبن عاش الدنيا غير الفاتحة
سابي قليلا القرن الكبير
واليك
لم يعد لدي هناك ولكن نفس القدرة على التحمل و
أنا حقًا نعم لا أستطيع
لا يتبع
لا أستطيع الخروج في نزهة على الأقدام ، أبلغ من العمر 60 عامًا
متر وأنا ممتن في النهاية
من الشارع انتهى الأمر ولكن أيضًا محلي
قانون الطماطم المتفاعل عالميًا
مثل الحميد لكنها استغلت فقط
البلاستيك هناك حالة مفصلة
ممارسات لدفع المصالح فيها
الحقيقة هي أن أتقن نفسي حقًا 12
والنفس من خلال القشة
الذي جعل ذلك يسمح لاثنين من
استرخاء اليورو التعاقد
فقيرة تتوقف عند ماكين ستحاول
ليتم إعادة تعيينه سيكون قد قدم إعلانه إلى
الخُبر بالشرق ماتنا من الخمر الذي نحن فيه
تخشى أنه تليف رئوي
مع العلم أنه مرض ممكن
تحدث بعد العديد من الأمراض
رئوي
بشكل عام ومجالاتها
بالنسبة لي الذين سيقولون تقريبًا
تنفس بشكل أقل أو أن الرئة لديها المزيد
من الصعب الشفط
انتهاء الصلاحية هناك البيع بالتجزئة و
المساعدات المتعلقة بالجيش
أخيرًا عليك إعادة تدريب ملف
الجسم لفعل كل شيء
كنت سأدرب على التنفس
أنا أتدرب على التحرك
يقود الذاكرة وبناءً على طلب مجاني ل
كولونا فرنسا تعلق على ماتا هويرة
تاريخ libanga أو Dubai الذي تم فيه
تقرير أخلاقي للشركة